hey everyone we're very excited to  announce that tickets are on sale for  marvel studios doctor strange in the  multiverse of madness  get ready for a mind-bending journey  through the multiverse  we're talking infinite impossibilities  things just got out of hand and infinite  realities  get your tickets now from marvel studios  dr strange in the multiverse of madness  only in theaters may 6th  [Music]  i've been  dreaming  the same  nightmare  the stranger  [Music]  the fate of the multiverse  depends on us  careful stephen  this path exacts a heavy toll  [Music]  okay  marvel studios dr strange in the  multiverse of madness only beaters may  6th as it gets on sale now  you